It was junior prom. David's date had ditched him and he wasn't doing so great. As he walked to get some cigarettes, he explained to me that the prom was the culmination of a three-year campaign on his part to get in with the cool crowd, a mostly white crowd. It began when he arrived at Lincoln Park High School.
那时是高二舞会。大卫的舞伴把他甩了，他当时状态不太好。在他走去买烟时，他向我解释说，舞会是他为了打入那个酷炫圈子（主要是白人圈子）而进行的一场长达三年活动的终极目标。这一切始于他刚到林肯公园高中的时候。
See, there's a story between here, right? When I was a freshman, when I first got to Lincoln Park, I was a total nerd, geeko, right? So of course I see all these glamorous, beautiful girls, and I'm like damn, wish I could-- only dream of having them, right? Or just taking them out on a date, not even doing anything physical with them, right?
你看，这中间有一段故事，对吧？我刚上高一，刚到林肯公园时，我是个十足的书呆子，怪胎，对吧？所以，我当然会看到那些迷人、美丽的女孩，我会想，天哪，我要是能——只能梦想着拥有她们，对吧？或者只是带她们出去约会，甚至不做任何身体接触，对吧？
First junior prom at Lincoln Park, the most gorgeous girl in school, I ask her to prom. She says yes. So goddamn! You know, I changed a lot. Since sophomore year, I got into this crowd and stuff, I just changed. I changed my speech, my dress, and all that stuff. I'm still the same person. I changed. This is the popular crowd. I mean, I'm just popular now.
林肯公园的第一场高二舞会，我邀请了学校里最漂亮的女孩。她答应了。太棒了！你知道，我改变了很多。从高二开始，我进入了这个圈子之类的，我变了。我改变了我的谈吐、着装，所有这一切。我还是同一个人，但我变了。这就是那个热门圈子。我是说，我现在只是很受欢迎。
So I end up going, right? And I know she has a history of being, like, incredibly moody. She's so gorgeous, take her anyway. You know, if I go with her this year, she's so gorgeous, then all these other girls are going to say, damn. I have to go with him now. If he's good enough for her, he's definitely good enough for me. I'm like fine, that's going to boost my rep a little bit.
所以我最终去了，对吧？我知道她以前一直情绪化得厉害。她太漂亮了，反正我也要带她去。你知道，如果我今年带她去，她那么漂亮，那么其他女孩就会说，天哪。我现在必须和他约会。如果他配得上她，那他绝对配得上我。我想，太好了，这会提升我的名气。
And I'll tell you this. I wanted something physical. I wanted to just fool around with her, meaning kiss her, kiss her, feel her up or whatever. Or even more, you know? Go all the way or whatever. But I wasn't counting on that. I was here to have fun. And that would be like a nice feature to it. That would be a bonus and all. I wasn't pushing her or anything.
而且我告诉你。我想要点身体接触。我只是想和她闹着玩，意思是亲吻她，亲吻她，摸摸她之类的。甚至更多，你知道吗？发生关系什么的。但我没指望那些。我是去玩的。如果能有那些那是再好不过的附加项了。那是意外收获。我并没有强迫她什么的。
Sure enough, her and her like alleged best friend get into a fight. And here I am alone with my rum and Coke.
果然，她和她所谓的最好的朋友吵架了。我就这样独自一人喝着朗姆可乐。
The prom. We don't make kids go into the army in this country. We don't make them go to college. We don't make them get married. But if they're still in school when they're 18, they collide with the impenetrable fact that is the prom. If they go to a school with a junior prom, they get it twice.
舞会。在这个国家，我们不强迫孩子参军。我们不强迫他们上大学。我们不强迫他们结婚。但如果他们18岁还在上学，他们就会撞上舞会这一不可逾越的事实。如果他们就读的学校有高二舞会，他们还要经历两次。
And then they have to take a stand. Go. Not go. Have some sort of experience. Use it to try to climb to a new group of friends. Use it to try to get the girl. Just try to get through it. The stakes are weirdly high. Good luck.
然后他们必须表明立场。去。还是不去。经历点什么。利用它来结交一群新朋友。利用它去追求那个女孩。只是试着熬过去。赌注高得离奇。祝你好运。
As we get older, I think a lot of people tend to roll their eyes at the idea of prom. I think because of the distance of years, there is something about it that just feels embarrassing. Certainly if you did not go, but even if you did. The clothes and the corsage and the corny music and the whole thing.
随着年龄增长，我想很多人往往对舞会的概念不屑一顾。我想因为时间的距离，它总有些让人感到尴尬的地方。当然，如果你没去过是这样，但即使你去过也是如此。那些衣服、胸花、俗气的音乐，所有的一切。
And I think we forget how thrilling it can be. It could be embarrassing to think how thrilled we once were to go out that night. How the whole thing just seems fraught with possibility to a lot of us.
我想我们忘记了它曾经是多么令人激动。想到我们曾经为了那个夜晚的出门而感到多么兴奋，可能会觉得很尴尬。对我们许多人来说，整件事似乎充满了可能性。
So today, on the very tail end of prom season, we bring you four stories of the prom. Let us understand it in its fullness, my friends. Now at last, as adults. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
所以今天，在舞会季的尾声，我们为您带来四个关于舞会的故事。让我们以成年人的视角，在最后时刻，真正理解它的全部含义。来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Act one of our program today. Tornado Prom. What happens when a natural disaster strikes the same tonight as the unnatural disaster that is the prom.
我们节目的第一幕，龙卷风舞会。当自然灾害在同一个夜晚袭来，撞上了名为舞会的“非自然灾害”时，会发生什么？
Act two. Save the Last Dance For Me... Again. Francine Pascal, the nominal author of 700 books for teenagers, including the Sweet Valley High books, explains why teen stories always have to end at the prom.
第二幕，把最后一支舞留给我……再一次。弗朗辛·帕斯卡尔，青少年读物《甜蜜谷高中》系列七百本书的署名作者，解释了为什么青春故事总是必须在舞会上结束。
Act three. Only Two Things Are Certain in Life: Death and Tuxes. In this act, you can experience over the radio a complete, typical prom. And look at the time. That just gives you half an hour to find a date.
第三幕，人生只有两件事是确定的：死亡和燕尾服。在这一幕中，你可以通过广播体验一场完整的、典型的舞会。看看时间，这只给了你半小时来找个舞伴。
Act One. Tornado Prom.
第一幕。龙卷风舞会。
In Hoisington, Kansas, a tornado hit on prom night. Hoisington is a small town of about 3,000. Nobody at the prom was hurt. In fact, nobody at prom knew it happened. But when prom was over, a third of the town was destroyed. One older man was dead. The seniors were left to figure out what to think of the whole thing. Susan Burton tells the story.
在堪萨斯州霍辛顿，一场龙卷风在舞会之夜来袭。霍辛顿是一个只有三千人的小镇。舞会上没有人受伤。事实上，舞会上的人根本不知道发生了什么。但当舞会结束时，三分之一的小镇已被摧毁。一位老人不幸遇难。高三学生们只能去思考如何面对这一切。苏珊·伯顿讲述了这个故事。
On Friday nights, the teenagers in Hoisington drag Main Street. Or they go to a party at someone's house, and the boys shoot baskets in the driveway, and the girls jump on the trampoline. Sometimes the parties are out the country, at ponds. "At six in the sticks," they tell me.
周五晚上，霍辛顿的青少年们会在主街上闲逛。或者他们会去某人家里参加聚会，男孩们在车道上投篮，女孩们在蹦床上跳跃。有时聚会在乡下的池塘边。“在乡下的六点钟，”他们对我这样说。
Since it's Kansas, there's weird weather. High winds that make the power flicker on and off. They get a lot of tornado warnings, but they never thought one would actually touch down here. Hoisington just seemed too boring to be visited by natural disaster.
因为是在堪萨斯州，天气很古怪。强风让电力忽明忽暗。他们经常收到龙卷风预警，但他们从未想过它真的会在这里着陆。霍辛顿看起来太无聊了，不像是会被自然灾害造访的地方。
It's just like, nothing happens in Hoisington. Like everyone says, oh, there ain't nothing to do in Hoisington. Nothing happens here. They're just like, why would a tornado come here?
就像是，霍辛顿什么都不会发生。就像每个人说的，哦，霍辛顿没什么可做的。这里什么都不会发生。他们只是觉得，龙卷风为什么要来这儿？
Prom actually feels grand in Hoisington. The day of the dance, the girls drive down to Great Bend and get their hair done at Main Attractions. They all wear long gowns. They shop for them at a store in Wichita that won't sell the dress you buy to anyone else in your town. The dresses are elaborate, and like all prime finery, extremely difficult to explain.
舞会在霍辛顿其实感觉很隆重。舞会当天，女孩们开车去大本德，在“主要景点”理发店做头发。她们都穿着长礼服。她们在威奇托的一家店里购买，那家店承诺不会把同款礼服卖给镇上的其他人。这些礼服很精致，就像所有高级饰品一样，极难解释清楚。
It's like black and it's fitted, but when you look at it from other directions, it's silver and royal blue. There's like two steps that go in the back and they cross. I don't know. It's hard to explain. Like people would ask me what it looked like, and it was so hard to explain to them, because it's just so unique.
它是黑色的，很合身，但当你从其他方向看它时，它是银色和宝蓝色的。背部有两根带子交叉。我不知道。很难解释。人们问我它看起来像什么，这对我来说很难描述，因为它太独特了。
All very long, tight-- not really any of them didn't have like a tight dress, or like, long-- they were just like one sheet, I guess. I really don't know about dresses. But there's just like one cloth.
都很长，很紧——几乎每件礼服都很紧，或者很长——我想它们就像是一整块布。我真的不太懂礼服。但它就像是一块布料做成的。
I don't know. I think prom's more of the female. You know. It's her night, you know? Most ladies are like, you know, want prom to be everything. So I think they wanted it to kind of be something, a night they'll never forget. And some of them got it.
我不知道。我觉得舞会更多是属于女性的。你知道。这是属于她的夜晚，对吧？大多数女士都希望舞会是一切。所以我认为她们想让它成为某种特别的，一个她们永生难忘的夜晚。有些人确实实现了。
I mean, I went through lots of prom magazines, just looking at themes and stuff. And we had the whole junior class vote on which one they wanted. And they came to be "Lost in the Moment." So it's kind of ironic. We really were lost in what was happening. We didn't know what was going on. So, I mean, after it, it's lost.
我是说，我翻阅了很多舞会杂志，寻找主题什么的。我们让整个高二班级投票选出他们想要的。最后选定了“迷失在瞬间”。所以这很有讽刺意味。我们确实迷失在正在发生的事情中。我们不知道发生了什么。所以，我是说，在那之后，一切都迷失了。
What happens when a prom meets a tornado, when two events that often end in disaster collide? The day that both the prom and the tornado came to Hoisington, everyone tells me, with ominous foreshadowing, started out sunny, looked stormy by dinner. It was sprinkling by the time everyone parked their trucks outside the Knights of Columbus Hall on Main Street. They ducked and ran inside to prom.
当舞会遇到龙卷风，当两个经常以灾难收场的事件碰撞在一起时会发生什么？每个人都用不祥的预兆告诉我，舞会和龙卷风同时来到霍辛顿的那天，起初阳光明媚，晚餐时看起来却要下暴雨。当大家把卡车停在主街的哥伦布骑士大厅外时，已经下起了小雨。他们低着头跑进舞会现场。
There was just a crowd of people taking pictures, I mean, like I was at a basketball game or something. Like ch-ch-ch-ch. Hurt my eyes after a little bit.
人群中到处是拍照的人，就像我在看篮球比赛什么的。咔嚓咔嚓。过了一会儿眼睛都疼了。
This is Sean. He's a junior. He videotaped the prom, partly so he could show his mom what she missed. From here, he and his classmates tell the story.
这是肖恩。他是一名高二学生。他给舞会录了像，部分原因是为了让他妈妈看看她错过了什么。从这里开始，他和同学们讲述了这个故事。
It took a minute before people, you know, finally started dancing and stuff.
过了一会儿，人们才终于开始跳舞之类的。
We got there late. So like, as soon as it-- we got there right at eight o'clock. So as soon as we got there, the dance had already started. We just started dancing. And we danced for, like, an hour or so, you know? Yeah, about an hour. And then the lights started flicking off and on. Like, it didn't flicker. It kind of went off, and then come back on, you know? And people just were-- some people, like my friend TyAnn is kind of scared of the dark, you know? So she's freaking out. But some people, it was just fun, you know? So normal blackout thing, you know?
我们到得很晚。所以，我们八点钟准时到达。所以我们一到，舞会就已经开始了。我们只是开始跳舞。我们跳了大约一个小时，你知道吗？对，大约一个小时。然后灯光开始忽明忽暗。就像，它并没有闪烁。它像是熄灭了，然后又亮起来，你知道吗？人们只是——有些人，比如我的朋友泰安，有点怕黑，你知道吗？所以她吓坏了。但有些人觉得这很有趣，你知道吗？正常的停电而已，你知道吗？
There was just a lot of people screaming and yelling, you know? Just acting like fools and stuff. I was too. And I got yelled at one time. Hand me that beer, break out the keg, and stuff like that. And the lights back on. Everybody just kind of looked around and went on their way, you know? Wasn't even anything big.
很多人在尖叫和大喊，你知道吗？像傻瓜一样胡闹。我也一样。我被吼了一次。把啤酒递给我，把桶拿出来什么的。灯又亮了。大家只是四处看了看，继续做自己的事，你知道吗？根本没什么大不了的。
The door kept opening. And we could hear, we knew it was getting windy outside. And someone had said that it had started to rain. And people would go out and look, and it was like rain was just coming in horizontally. It was just blowing down the street. And we didn't think anything of it. It was just oh, you know, we have to go out in this later. Didn't think it was as bad as what it was.
门一直开着。我们能听到，我们知道外面风很大。有人说开始下雨了。人们跑出去看，雨像是横着吹进来的。它在街上呼啸而过。我们没想太多。只是觉得，哦，你知道，我们晚点还得出去。没觉得情况有多严重。
They were playing "I'm a Survivor" from Destiny's Child. And that was like the next to last song before the lights blacked out. Who would know, you know? I mean, who would've thought that that song would be playing one of the last times that a tornado-- right before it rips through our town, you know?
他们当时正在放真命天女组合的《我是幸存者》。那是灯光熄灭前倒数第二首歌。谁能知道呢，你知道吗？我是说，谁能想到这首歌会是在龙卷风撕裂我们小镇前，最后播放的曲目之一呢，你知道吗？
Lights went out the second time. And everybody just kind of stood around and everything, waiting. And we're like, hurry up. Turn the lights back on. Come on, this sucks. We're standing around at prom, you know?
第二次熄灯。每个人都只是站在那里等待。我们想，快点。把灯打开。得了吧，这太烂了。我们站在舞会上，你知道吗？
DJs came out, and they had like a long stick, and they were trying to get everyone to do like a limbo. Just to keep us entertained while the lights were out, because they couldn't have any music or anything like that. So they had a line of limbo going through. And that was when our principal told us that we needed to go downstairs.
DJ出来了，他们拿了一根长棍子，试图让每个人玩凌波舞。只是为了在停电时让我们保持娱乐，因为他们没法放音乐什么的。所以他们排成了一队玩凌波舞。就在那时，校长告诉我们必须下楼去。
Shortly after the lights went out, the door of the Knights of Columbus then was basically sucked open.
灯熄灭后不久，哥伦布骑士大厅的门基本上是被吸开的。
This is Mike Nolton, the principal of Hoisington High School.
这是迈克·诺尔顿，霍辛顿高中的校长。
At that point, I walked over, and you could feel the pane glass kind of vibrating a little bit. And it subsided a little bit. I stepped outside, and as I stepped outside, an ambulance was coming down the Main Street with the PA saying, "Get in the basement,"
那一刻，我走过去，你可以感觉到玻璃窗在轻微地颤动。然后颤动稍微平息了一些。我走到外面，当我走到外面时，一辆救护车正沿着主街开过来，高音喇叭里喊着：“进地下室。”
"KSN news. Here's a break. We've got bad weather outside. They're locking us in. We can't get out to get more beer and drugs. So Hoisington's crowded. People are scared. The wind is blowing, and the rain is coming down hard. Everybody go to the basement and take shelter. Get away from the windows. Get in your bathtub. Pull a mattress over your head. Secure yourself. This is serious, folks. I'm out."
“KSN新闻。插播消息。外面天气很糟糕。他们把我们锁在里面了。我们没法出去买更多的啤酒和毒品。所以霍辛顿人满为患。人们很害怕。风在吹，雨下得很大。所有人去地下室避难。远离窗户。躲进浴缸里。拿个床垫盖在头上。保护好自己。情况很严重，各位。我先撤了。”
I was just taping and she just came up and just started saying that stuff. And I talked to her afterwards, and she had no idea there was a tornado. She feels bad for even saying that stuff, so. It was like, whoa. She was right on the money.
我当时只是在录像，她就走过来开始说那些话。后来我跟她谈过，她根本不知道有龙卷风。她为说了那些话感到内疚。这简直是，哇。她竟然说准了。
"This is the best prom ever. Ever! The basement. Right here."
“这是史上最棒的舞会。史上最棒的！地下室。就在这儿。”
"Oh my God, I can't see. There you are."
“天哪，我看不见。你在那里。”
"Someone's smoking down here."
“有人在下面抽烟。”
"Are you serious?"
“你是认真的吗？”
"I can smell it!"
“我能闻到！”
It was dark, and we were having troubles seeing everybody. And Mr. Nolton said that we weren't allowed to go-- our principal said we weren't allowed to go upstairs until the cops came and told us that everything was OK. And I asked him, I was like, well, are we down here because of hailstorm, thunderstorm, tornado, what's going on? He's like, well, right now, everything would be speculation.
当时很黑，我们看不清每个人。诺尔顿先生说我们不准上去——我们的校长说，在警察来并告诉我们一切安全之前，不准上去。我问他，我说，好吧，我们在这儿是因为冰雹、雷暴、龙卷风，还是发生了什么？他说，好吧，现在一切都是猜测。
Is it hail, is it tornadoes, or what?
是冰雹、龙卷风，还是别的什么？
"Right now it'd be speculation on my part. All I know is that it did some damage to some homes. Quiet, please. We will keep you here until it's safe to turn you loose. And then we will make the decision on whether to reschedule prom. Must be a popular decision. I'm sorry."
“目前这只是我的猜测。我只知道它对一些房屋造成了破坏。请安静。我们会让你们留在这里直到安全为止。然后我们将决定是否重新安排舞会。这一定是个受欢迎的决定。很抱歉。”
I made the call that prom would be cancelled. Two hours later, I looked back on that statement and I thought, boy, that was a silly statement. I didn't even have to make that statement. There wasn't even going to be a kid there that wanted to stay at prom. It just goes to show how little we knew. And we were four blocks away from the storm.
我做出了取消舞会的决定。两个小时后，我回想那个声明，心想，天哪，那真是个愚蠢的声明。我甚至不需要发表那个声明。当时根本没孩子想留在舞会上。这正说明了我们所知甚少。我们离风暴只有四个街区。
And so that's when like, people that would have cellphones, they started getting on those. And a lot of rumors were flying through, and people were saying-- I mean, it was like OK. All of a sudden, someone pops up and says, Zack, your house is gone. Or like, Jacob, your sister's house is gone. And then it was like, all of 5th Street's gone. All of 6th Street's gone.
也就是那时候，有手机的人开始用手机。很多传言四起，人们说——我是说，就像是好吧。突然，有人冒出来说，扎克，你的房子没了。或者，雅各布，你姐姐的房子没了。然后就像是，第五街全没了。第六街全没了。
I was just like, don't jump to conclusions, because you don't know what's true, and what's a lie, and what's a rumor. There was rumors flying everywhere. That Dairy Queen was gone, and everybody that was in it was dead. And I mean, that was where we were going to have breakfast at, after prom.
我当时就想，别急着下结论，因为你不知道什么是真，什么是假，什么是传言。到处都是传言。说奶品皇后店没了，里面的人都死了。我的意思是，那本来是我们舞会后吃早餐的地方。
There's people crying, because we can't leave. We don't know where our families are at. We didn't know how to get a hold of anybody. It was-- I don't even know if I can explain the feeling. It was just like-- I was just so scared. It was almost-- you couldn't even really talk. All I could do was cry. That's all I could do.
有人在哭，因为我们不能离开。我们不知道家人们在哪里。我们不知道该怎么联系任何人。这——我甚至不知道该如何解释那种感觉。我只是——我太害怕了。简直是——你甚至无法说话。我唯一能做的就是哭。我唯一能做的就是这些。
"I'm about ready to cry, so I'm going to turn out again."
“我准备好要哭了，所以我又要关机了。”
All of a sudden, everybody just started walking upstairs, you know? And it was still dark. And I was looking for my coat, because I'd taken it off and set it on a chair. And me and this other guy, Luke Patton, we both had the same looking bouttoniere. So we were looking at it, and he was like, that looks like mine. And his girlfriend was like, yeah, that's yours. I can tell by that one. I was like, are you sure? He's like, I don't know how the can of chew got in here, but you can have it.
突然，大家都开始往楼上走，你知道吗？外面还是很黑。我在找我的外套，因为我把它脱下来放在椅子上了。我和另一个人，卢克·巴顿，我们俩的胸花看起来一模一样。所以我们盯着看，他当时就说，看起来像我的。他女朋友说，没错，那是你的。我能从那个看出来。我说，你确定吗？他说，我不知道那罐咀嚼烟草怎么在这儿，但你可以拿去。
So I kept it, and I was looking for it, and I couldn't find it, I couldn't find it. And then I heard somebody yell my name, and I thought, that's my brother. No. What would he be doing up here, you know? And then he's like, Will, you've got to talk to mom. So I figured, oh, she's overreacting. She wants to talk to me, make sure I'm OK.
所以我留着它，我一直在找外套，但我找不到，找不到。然后我听到有人喊我的名字，我想，那是我哥哥。不。他怎么会在这儿呢，你知道吗？然后他说，威尔，你得跟我妈谈谈。所以我心想，哦，她在反应过度。她想跟我说话，确认我没事。
And I could kind of see her. You know? There's a little bit of light coming from the doorway, where you can make out somebody's figure. And I could kind of tell it was my mom. So I walked up to her. She started crying. And my sister was sitting there crying. And I just kind of was like, oh no. The last time I heard her sound that worried and scared was when my dad died. That was the last I ever heard my mom sound that bad.
我能隐约看到她。你知道吗？门口透出的一点微光，你可以分辨出某人的轮廓。我能看出那是妈妈。所以我向她走去。她开始哭。我姐姐坐在那里哭。我只是心想，哦不。上次听到她声音那么担心、那么害怕是在我爸爸去世的时候。那是我最后一次听到妈妈听起来那么糟糕。
I kind of sat there. And I didn't believe it at first. Because I was like, tornado? What tornado? There's no tornado. We didn't know about any tornado. I didn't think there was, because I didn't see it, you know? I was right here. You know? How could there be a tornado without us knowing?
我坐在那里。起初我不相信。因为我想，龙卷风？什么龙卷风？没有龙卷风。我们根本不知道有什么龙卷风。我不认为有，因为我没看到，你知道吗？我就在这儿。你知道吗？没有我们知道怎么可能发生龙卷风？
Will and his mom went outside. Everyone from prom was standing on the sidewalk. Main Street looked fine. None of the buildings seemed to have been touched. The air felt nice and cool. At first Will thought the cars were pockmarked, like from hail. But then he realized the storm had just covered them with little white flowers.
威尔和他妈妈走到外面。舞会上的每个人都站在人行道上。主街看起来完好无损。没有任何建筑物看起来遭到破坏。空气感觉凉爽宜人。起初威尔以为车上的痕迹是冰雹留下的。但后来他意识到风暴只是在它们身上覆盖了一层白色的小花。
No one, like, actually came up and said, oh, it was a tornado. It was. There was someone saying, like, "him, come here. You, come here. You, come here." And it was weird, because you were like kind of listening for your name if it was coming up. And it was just like that. One row, a street, like 6th and 7th. I mean, that's where, like, all the kids they were naming off that lived on that street. And it was like, wait a minute, you know. Did it hit up there?
没有人走过来具体说，哦，那是龙卷风。有个人说，“你，过来。你，过来。你，过来。”这很奇怪，因为你会像在听自己的名字会不会被叫到一样。就是那样。一排，一条街，比如第六街和第七街。我是说，住在那些街上的孩子们都被叫到了。就像是，等一下，你知道。是往那边袭击的吗？
Oh, there was like so many fire trucks and so many cops. Ambulances. I mean, they were just going north, just kept on going north. Didn't turn or nothing. It just went north. And they kind of like lit the whole town when they went through.
哦，到处都是消防车和警察。救护车。我是说，他们只是向北走，一直向北走。没有转弯什么的。它只是向北走了。当他们经过时，照亮了整个小镇。
And then you look on the other side of town, it's like totally dark. It was weird. Because it was like pitch black, basically, down there. it was kind of like, if you drove north, you're going to fall into a black hole or something.
然后你看看小镇的另一边，完全是黑的。很诡异。因为那儿基本上是漆黑一片。就像，如果你开车向北，你会掉进一个黑洞什么的。
We drove around for a while, and I couldn't believe. When I saw, like, houses-- like the one house had, like, a big chunk ripped out of the top of it. Like a T-rex walked up and just took a bite out of the top of the roof and stuff.
我们开车转了一会儿，我不敢相信。当我看到，比如，房子——有一栋房子的顶部被撕掉了一大块。就像霸王龙走过来从屋顶咬了一口什么的。
My cousin had a separate car from my aunt, so he took me as close as he could get me to my house. And then I just got out and I ran to my house. I was jumping over power lines and tree limbs and everything in my prom dress and flip flops. But I got there.
我表哥有另外的车，所以他带我尽可能靠近我家。然后我下车跑向我家。我穿着舞会礼服和人字拖，跳过电线和树枝。但我到了。
This is Elana. She lived on 6th Street, right where the tornado hit.
这是埃拉娜。她住在第六街，正是龙卷风袭击的地方。
My mom said she cooked us supper that night. She had a crystal pitcher of like iced tea sitting our table. And it was still fine. After the tornado, it was still sitting like right there, on the exact spot on the table. It hadn't been touched at all. And the roof was completely off the kitchen. You could stand in our kitchen and look up and you'd be looking up at the sky.
我妈说那天晚上她给我们做了晚餐。桌上放着一壶冰茶。它仍然完好无损。龙卷风过后，它依然稳稳地立在桌上原来的位置。完全没动过。但厨房的屋顶全没了。你可以站在我们的厨房里抬头看，你就能看到天空。
That night kids walked all over Hoisington with flashlights. All the places they could think to go. The Dairy Queen, the bowling alley, the grocery store, the football field were gone. It wasn't just that something had finally happened in Hoisington. Hoisington had become an entirely different town.
那天晚上，孩子们拿着手电筒走遍了霍辛顿。他们能想到的所有地方。奶品皇后、保龄球馆、杂货店、足球场都没了。这不仅仅是霍辛顿终于发生了点什么。霍辛顿已经变成了另一个截然不同的城镇。
Where we're in right now is Ground Zero. My house is in Ground Zero.
我们现在所在的地方是震中。我家就在震中。
I arrived in Hoisington about two weeks after the tornado, and Elana took me on a tour.
我在龙卷风发生大约两周后到达霍辛顿，埃拉娜带我参观了一圈。
Everything is normal on the side. You can't even tell anything ever happened.
这边的所有东西都很正常。你甚至看不出发生过什么。
Whole sections of the town were still perfect. There were people on porches and shiny party balloons tied to mailboxes. Then we crossed over. A lot of the west side had already been bulldozed. Now it was just dirt and basements and house parts. Someone's front steps or a kitchen cut away like a room in a dollhouse.
镇上的整个区域仍然很完美。门廊上有人，信箱上系着闪亮的派对气球。然后我们穿了过去。西边的大部分地区已经被推土机铲平了。现在只剩下泥土、地下室和房屋碎片。某人的前台阶或者厨房像玩偶屋里的房间一样被切开了。
And of course, this is Kansas. The main street in town is a red brick road. Lots of people had spray painted their cars and houses and boarded-up windows with references to the Wizard of Oz.
当然，这是堪萨斯州。镇上的主街是红砖路。许多人把他们的车和房子、木板封死的窗户上喷漆，引用了《绿野仙踪》的梗。
Everybody writes stuff about Dorothy and Toto on their house. It's like our house-- we had all the windows boarded shut, and we had all kinds of sayings on there. We had, like, "We're coming for you, Toto," and like, "Dear Dorothy, I miss you. If somebody finds me, please pack me and send me to Oklahoma. Love, Toto."
每个人都在他们的房子上写着关于多萝西和托托的东西。就像我们的房子——所有的窗户都钉死了，上面写着各种语录。我们写着，“我们来找你了，托托”，还有，“亲爱的多萝西，我好想你。如果有人找到我，请把我打包寄回俄克拉荷马州。爱你的，托托。”
To the kids in Hoisington, it started to seem like the Tornado made choices. Why would it knock down a house but not even break the glass on a framed photograph of bridesmaids in purple dresses?
对于霍辛顿的孩子们来说，龙卷风似乎是有选择的。为什么它会摧毁一栋房子，却甚至没能打碎一张镶框照片里穿着紫色礼服的伴娘的玻璃？
All kinds of weird stuff has happened. Like when they went in Adam's room, the only thing that they found left in the room was the movie Twister. And some people found a prom glass in their cupboard, and it's from 1963. And they didn't have any kids. They're an old couple. They didn't have any kids that graduated that year. They have no idea where it came from. But they found it in their cupboard.
发生了很多奇怪的事情。比如当他们走进亚当的房间时，他们发现房间里剩下的唯一东西是电影《龙卷风》。有些人从碗柜里找到了一个舞会酒杯，那是1963年的。他们没有孩子。那是一对老夫妇。他们没有孩子在那一年毕业。他们不知道这东西是从哪儿来的。但他们确实在碗柜里找到了它。
Some teenagers started to look for a logic in who was hit and who was spared. I'm told that the junior class got it the worst, and that it's a known fact they've been jinxed since the fourth grade. Addie, who lost her house, and Brooke, who didn't, tell me that Addie has bad luck and Brooke has good luck, that they joke about this all the time. That even at the moment the tornado destroyed Hoisington, Brooke was winning a prize at prom.
一些青少年开始试图寻找谁被袭击、谁幸免的逻辑。我听说高二班级受灾最重，而且这是一个众所周知的事实，他们从四年级开始就一直被诅咒。失去了房子的阿迪和没有失去房子的布鲁克告诉我，阿迪运气不好，而布鲁克运气好，她们总是拿这件事开玩笑。甚至在龙卷风摧毁霍辛顿的那一刻，布鲁克还在舞会上赢得了奖品。
Will took the whole thing a lot harder.
威尔对整件事感到痛苦得多。
Seems like, you know, that we just can't get a break. That we just can't get lucky.
感觉就像，你知道，我们就是无法获得喘息的机会。我们就是无法获得好运。
Will's dad died several years ago-- had a heart attack on his birthday. And then last fall, the house Will had lived in since he was little got too expensive for his mother and the family had to move out. The house was on the east side and the tornado didn't touch it.
威尔的爸爸几年前去世了——在他生日那天心脏病发作。去年秋天，威尔从小住到大的房子对她母亲来说太贵了，一家人不得不搬走。那房子在东边，龙卷风没碰到它。
Even still, when I drive by there, I look at the house and wonder what it would have been like if the tornado hit and we still lived at that house, you know? And I wonder, if I still lived there, would the tornado have come that way and hit us there? You know? Because maybe it was hit because there was somebody that it was going after, you know? And if I did live in that other house, that maybe I would have-- you know, the tornado probably would have came out over on the east side. That it probably still would've come through and done something to the houses. Just the way I believe.
尽管如此，当我开车经过那里时，我看着那房子，想如果龙卷风袭击了那里，而我们还住在那个房子里，会是什么样子，你知道吗？我想，如果我还住在那里，龙卷风会不会朝那个方向走，袭击我们，你知道吗？因为也许它会被袭击是因为有什么人是它的目标，你知道吗？如果我确实住在那个房子里，也许我会——你知道，龙卷风大概会到东边去。它大概还是会穿过去对房子造成破坏。这就是我的信仰。
I think it was meant to teach me a lesson in a couple ways. Like I always thought, oh, it would be cool if we had a tornado in this town. You know? To have something exciting going on. And now it's like, well here. Have a tornado. Now how do you feel about it?
我认为这是为了以几种方式给我上一课。比如我总是想，哦，如果我们镇上有龙卷风就酷了。你知道吗？能发生点刺激的事情。现在就像是，好吧，给你。来个龙卷风。现在你感觉如何？
Elana felt like she caused the storm, too.
埃拉娜也觉得是她引发了风暴。
Friday night before the tornado, me and Addie, we were driving to Claflin to hang out with some friends. And I was like, "you know, Addie?" I was like, "I've never seen a tornado. I really want to see one sometime." She's like "oh, Lanie, they're really scary." She's like, "I've seen a couple, but I've never actually been in one." I was like, "I know. Wouldn't that be crazy if it really did happen?"
龙卷风发生前的周五晚上，我和阿迪开车去克拉弗林和朋友们闲逛。我说，“你知道吗，阿迪？” 我说，“我从没见过龙卷风。我真的很想看一次。” 她说，“哦，雷尼，它们真的很可怕。” 她说，“我见过几次，但我从未真正身处其中。” 我说，“我知道。如果真的发生了不是很疯狂吗？”
And then like 24 hours almost exactly later, you know, the next night, a tornado comes and takes out our houses. It was pretty freaky. I was just like, oh my gosh. I remember after the tornado, when I got home, I was crying. I was talking to my mom. And I was just like, "I swear I made this happen." And my mom was like, "no, Lanie. You didn't make it happen."
然后大约24小时后，你知道，第二天晚上，龙卷风来了，带走了我们的房子。这真的很诡异。我当时就像，哦天哪。我记得龙卷风过后，当我回到家，我哭了。我跟我妈说话。我只是说，“我发誓是我让这一切发生的。” 我妈说，“不，雷尼。不是你让它发生的。”
But I mean, it's pretty scary. Saying, "I've never seen one, I really want to see one," the night before it takes out my house.
但我的意思是，这真的很吓人。在它毁掉我房子的前一天晚上说“我从没见过，我真的很想看一次”。
I ask Sean if he thinks the storm singled people out.
我问肖恩他是否认为风暴是针对个人的。
I don't think so, really. Because if that was true, it would have come straight to my house and would have found me at prom.  But it didn't. I don't know. I have, like, bad luck all the time. I mean like, two sisters, the first one was the littlest one. She said, "oh, I'll go to prom with you," and she dumps me. Her sister asked me to prom, then she's like, "well, I don't want to go with you. I want to go with someone else." So it was like I got rejected by sisters. So it's like, [SIGH].
我不这么认为，真的。因为如果那是真的，它会直奔我家，并在舞会上找到我。但它没有。我不知道。我总是运气很差。我是说，两个姐妹，第一个是年纪最小的。她说，“哦，我会和你去舞会”，然后她甩了我。她的姐妹请我去舞会，然后她说，“好吧，我不想和你去。我想和别人去。” 所以就像我被姐妹俩拒绝了。所以就像，[叹气]。
So it should have found me and like, sucked me up by myself, just to be like, ha ha ha, you know? And then hit my car, and then hit my room. So just hit my house. Just my room and my car. So I'd scratch that bad luck idea with some people. It was just a twist of fate that that happened.
所以它应该找到我，把我吸走，就像是，哈哈，你知道吗？然后撞击我的车，撞击我的房间。所以直接撞击我的房子。就撞我的房间和车。所以我放弃了某些人的厄运论。这一切只是命运的扭曲。
That was definitely the prom of all proms. I mean, it was a horrible, horrible experience to go through. But it was definitely a prom of all proms.
那绝对是舞会中的舞会。我是说，那是一次极其可怕的经历。但它绝对是舞会中的舞会。
I mean, it's like something that everybody's going to remember. Like some people, they look back on prom and it's just a prom night. You know? Everybody knows what's going to happen at prom, and they know what prom is. But now we can say what happened on prom night, and it's a really big event now, you know?
我的意思是，这是每个人都会记住的事情。就像有些人回望舞会，那只是一个舞会之夜。你知道吗？每个人都知道舞会上会发生什么，他们知道什么是舞会。但现在我们可以说舞会之夜发生了什么，这现在成了一个非常大的事件，你知道吗？
I guess it's one that you'll never forget, really. I mean, you think of prom night, now you think of tornado. I mean, everybody's going to remember it for that.
我想这是一次你永远不会忘记的经历，真的。我是说，你想到舞会之夜，现在就会想到龙卷风。我是说，每个人都会因此记住它。
Usually the story of prom is one of disappointment. You're in the bathroom crying during the slow dance, or you throw up at the hotel room party, or you go home feeling silly for having been so excited about something so meaningless. The teenagers in Hoisington got the kind of prom story everybody wants. They got a legendary prom-- the night that actually did change their lives.
通常舞会的故事总是伴随着失望。你在慢舞时躲在厕所哭，或者你在酒店房间的派对上呕吐，或者你回家时因为对毫无意义的事情感到兴奋而觉得自己很傻。霍辛顿的青少年们得到了每个人都想要的舞会故事。他们得到了一个传说中的舞会——那个真正改变了他们一生的夜晚。
I mean, it's like-- I went to prom my sophomore and junior years. And it was a dance. It was a prom. It was nice, and it was fun to get all dressed up. But it was like a prom that taught a lesson, you know? It wasn't just-- it became our cars and clothes weren't more so important, and family and friends, and-- it taught a big lesson about humanity, I think, to everybody there. Everybody had a new perspective of life, walking out of that prom.
我的意思是，就像——我高二高三都参加了舞会。那是个舞会。那是个舞会。它很美好，打扮起来也很有趣。但这是一个教会我们一课的舞会，你知道吗？它不仅仅是——它成了我们的车和衣服不再那么重要了，家庭和朋友，以及——我认为它给在场的每个人上了一堂关于人性的重要课程。走出那个舞会，每个人对生活都有了新的视角。
We were in, like, a whole different world. Just having fun, when actually outside it's like totally opposite. People are in their basements. Stuff's falling down. Houses are gone. People are actually losing stuff. And we're in prom still, dancing, when the tornado hits and after it hits. We're still just, you know, free of everything. Still having a good time. It's like totally different when you walk outside. Like you step out of the safe zone and you go into another world where reality hits.
我们当时处于一个完全不同的世界。只是玩得很开心，而实际上外面却是完全相反的。人们躲在地下室里。东西倒塌。房子没了。人们真的失去了东西。而我们还在舞会上，跳着舞，龙卷风来了，在它袭击之后。我们仍然，你知道，摆脱了一切。仍然玩得很开心。当你走出去时，一切都完全不同了。就像你走出了安全区，进入了另一个现实冲击你的世界。
Prom doesn't usually chaperone you into the world so quickly. Suddenly a lot of kids in Hoisington have to act like grownups. Will's going to college in the fall, but he sometimes thinks it would be better to get a job on an oil rig, give the paychecks to his mother. A senior named Zack actually pulled his parents out of the rubble of their own home on prom night.
舞会通常不会引导你这么快进入世界。突然间，霍辛顿的许多孩子不得不像成年人一样行事。威尔秋天要上大学，但他有时觉得在石油钻井平台上找份工作，把工资交给母亲会更好。一个叫扎克的毕业生在舞会之夜亲自把父母从他们家自己的废墟中拉了出来。
But everyone's looking forward to rebuilding, and they're all getting used to the idea that anything can happen. Even in Hoisington.
但每个人都期待着重建，他们都在适应任何事情都可能发生的想法。即使是在霍辛顿。
Susan Burton in New York.
苏珊·伯顿，纽约。
Since we first broadcast that story back in 2001, Will, the teenager who talked about how doomed he felt, how his family couldn't get a break, whose father died and whose house was destroyed-- he died in July in a car accident, just a few months after prom and just weeks after our story was broadcast.
自我们2001年首次播出那个故事以来，那个讨论自己感觉多倒霉、家庭无法获得喘息、父亲去世且房子被毁的少年威尔——他在舞会后仅几个月、我们节目播出后仅几周，就死于一场车祸。
Well, coming up. They've been juniors in high school since 1982. So when they say-- and this is a direct quote-- "We've been dreaming about prom night for years"-- they mean it. In a minute on Public Radio International when our program continues.
好了，接下来。他们从1982年起就是高中高二学生了。所以当他们说——这是直接引用——“我们多年来一直梦想着舞会之夜”——他们是认真的。稍后在国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, at the very end of prom season, stories about the prom.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，为您带来各种各样的相关故事。今天的节目，在舞会季即将结束之际，是关于舞会的故事。
We've arrived at act two of our program. Act Two. Save the Last Dance For Me... Again.
我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕。把最后一支舞留给我……再一次。
So Pretty in Pink, and Carrie, and Back to the Future, and the Cosby Kids, and Buffy, and too many other movies and TV shows to name-- they all eventually end up at the prom. But why? Why the prom? Why is it so omnipresent?
所以《粉红佳人》、《魔女嘉莉》、《回到未来》、《考斯比一家》、《吸血鬼猎人巴菲》，以及太多不胜枚举的电影和电视剧——它们最终都以舞会结尾。但为什么？为什么是舞会？为什么它如此无处不在？
Well, for answers we turn to Francine Pascal, who has written or invented the plot lines for 700 books in the Sweet Valley High series. Which, of course, is the adventures of Elizabeth and Jessica Wakefield, twins and-- well, seemingly permanent high school juniors. She spoke to us from her home in France.
好吧，为了寻找答案，我们请教了弗朗辛·帕斯卡尔，她撰写或创作了《甜蜜谷高中》系列七百本书的情节。当然，那是关于伊丽莎白和杰西卡·韦克菲尔德这对双胞胎的冒险故事——嗯，似乎是永远的高二学生。她在法国的家中接受了我们的采访。
Well, I have to tell you that the prom is probably the quintessential glory of high school. It's the moment that comes closest to the romantic vision of life. I think it's repeated again only one other time, and that would be marriage. I mean, it's that important in the high school life, in the teenager life, in that pre-life before adult.
好吧，我得告诉你，舞会可能是高中生活的精髓所在。它是最接近浪漫生活愿景的时刻。我想它只有在另一种场合会被再次重复，那就是婚礼。我是说，它在高中生活、在青少年生活中、在那步入成年之前的生命阶段里就是那么重要。
That's interesting. So as in a traditional drama where you'd want the characters to end up in marriage, if you're writing about teenagers, all you've got is the prom.
这很有趣。所以，就像在传统戏剧中你会希望角色最终走向婚姻一样，如果你在写青少年的故事，你唯一拥有的就是舞会。
That's about it. That's right. And out of the 700 books, I probably-- prom is mentioned in at least 500 of them. But I would say it's probably a major goal in almost 30. 35.
差不多就是这样。没错。在那七百本书中，舞会在其中至少五百本里被提到。但我想说它在大约三十五本书里是一个主要目标。
You mean 35 or so books actually take place at the prom? There's an actual prom in them?
你是说有三十五本书左右实际上发生在舞会上？里面真的有舞会情节？
Yes. There is a prom as the plot goal, or a very important part of the plot. I can give you just ideas of it. I think in the second book I did a plot about who is going to be the king and queen of the prom? And there was, you know, rigging the election. And just to give you an idea. Plots on getting a date for the prom, somebody who has no date to the prom, the wrong day to the prom, the wrong date that turns that our right for the prom. And I know there was a plot about this poor girl, her brother had to take her. I mean, that's permanent trauma. And then the other thing, but there's no money for the prom dress. And there's the one about, you think he's going to ask you, but he asks someone else. And every-- I mean, when you're involved in as many plots as I am, they begin to fall into some categories. And there are things like the bet plot.
是的。有一场舞会作为情节目标，或者作为情节中非常重要的一部分。我可以给你举几个例子。我想在第二本书里我写了一个情节：谁会成为舞会的国王和皇后？并且有，你知道，操纵选举的戏码。只是给你个概念。关于舞会舞伴的情节，没舞伴去舞会的人，去舞会的错误日子，去舞会的错误舞伴，那个错误的舞伴在舞会上变成了正确的。我知道有一个关于这个可怜女孩的情节，她的哥哥不得不带她去。我是说，那是永久的创伤。然后另一件事，比如没有钱买舞会礼服。还有一个情节是，你以为他会邀请你，但他邀请了别人。我是说，当你参与了那么多情节时，它们开始归入某些类别。有些东西就像赌注情节。
The what plot?
什么情节？
The bet. Wager, like a wager. A bet plot, or the pledge plot. Where the boy asks the girl on a bet to go to the prom. Or the pledge is, he has to ask the least popular girl in the class to go to the prom, and then she finds out, and then he really wants to go with her, but it's too late because she's furious. And that takes a whole book to settle down.
赌注。打赌，就像赌博。赌注情节，或者誓言情节。男孩因为打赌邀请女孩去舞会。或者誓言是，他必须邀请班上最不受欢迎的女孩去舞会，然后她发现了，他其实真的很想和她去，但已经太迟了，因为她狂怒不已。这需要整整一本书来解决。
It seems like one of the common prom plots is that the prom forces a choice between potential dates. And often it'll be the good-looking unattainable boy or girl is one possibility and the smart, funny best friend is the other possibility.
看起来舞会的一个常见情节是舞会强迫人们在潜在的舞伴之间做出选择。通常是帅气但高不可攀的男孩或女孩是一种可能，而聪明幽默的最好的朋友是另一种可能。
Exactly. Exactly. I've used that sort of thing. It's also perfect, because though these people are not going to be living for the rest of their lives, they're not legally married or anything, but they do have to make that first important choice of the person they are going to spend that momentous evening with. And it's a mini-marriage kind of choice.
完全正确。完全正确。我也用过类似的东西。它也很完美，因为虽然这些人不会余生都在一起，他们没有法律意义上的结婚，但他们确实必须做出人生中第一个重要的选择——与他们共度那个重大夜晚的人。这是一种迷你婚姻的选择。
In book number 142 in the Sweet Valley series, a story called The Big Night, you have not one, not two, not three, but four characters who end up switching their dates at the prom. Then one girl tries to kill her date.
在《甜蜜谷》系列第142本书中，有个故事叫《大夜晚》，你不仅有一个，不是两个，不是三个，而是四个角色最终在舞会上交换了舞伴。然后一个女孩试图杀了她的舞伴。
Oh! That must have been a thriller.
哦！那一定是个惊悚片。
Courtney tries to push Todd off of a boat railing into the water. And Elizabeth is in a speedboat following.
考特尼试图把托德从船栏杆上推到水里。而伊丽莎白就在后面的一艘快艇上追赶。
Yes, right. Well, you know, that's just a variation on a theme. That's all. You have to do something slightly different with them when you're on 140.
是的，没错。嗯，你知道，那只是主题的变体。仅此而已。当你写到第140本时，你必须对它们做点稍微不同的处理。
Listening to you talk about this, it seems like what the prom does, and what it gives you as writer, is it gives you a natural arena where there can be a conflict over love and an outcome. And without the prom, you'd have to invent some situation which would feel like it has weight, whereas the prom just has the weight.
听你谈论这个，似乎舞会所做的，以及它作为作家能带给你的，是一个自然的竞技场，在那里可以产生爱的冲突和结果。如果没有舞会，你必须发明某种感觉有分量的处境，而舞会本身就自带分量。
Exactly. Because the prom is-- it's a natural. It comes filled with all kinds of emotion. Just the mention of the prom-- you don't have to create something, and build it up, and give it terrible importance. You don't have to do any of those things.
完全正确。因为舞会是——它是天生的。它自带各种各样的情感。只要提到舞会——你不需要创造某种东西，构建它，赋予它可怕的重要性。你不需要做任何这些事情。
Did you go to prom yourself?
你自己参加过舞会吗？
I never went to my own prom. I was not interested. Strangely enough. I didn't like high school very much at all. It's funny that I ended up writing so much about it.
我自己从没去过自己的舞会。我不感兴趣。奇怪的是。我根本不喜欢高中生活。好笑的是我最终写了那么多关于它的东西。
And what did you think of prom?
那你觉得舞会怎么样？
I really was not interested. I felt that I was too sophisticated and mature for that sort of stuff. And I just didn't-- I never really participated. Beyond writing speeches for the political candidates and being on the newspaper. That's what I liked. But beyond that, I just didn't have an interest in it.
我真的没兴趣。我觉得我对于那种事情来说太成熟老练了。我只是没——我从未真正参与过。除了为政治候选人写演讲稿和在校报工作。那是我喜欢的。但除此之外，我真的没兴趣。
You never cared to go to the prom, and so you've now, somehow fate has put you in a situation where you've had to revisit it over 35 times.
你从来不在乎去舞会，所以现在，某种命运把你放在了一个不得不重访它三十五次以上的境地。
That's right. Yes, it's my punishment. But it's different because I don't have to show up there.
没错。是的，这是对我的惩罚。但它不同，因为我不必亲自出现在那里。
The charming Francine Pascal, creator of Sweet Valley High.
迷人的弗朗辛·帕斯卡尔，《甜蜜谷高中》的创作者。
Act Three. Death and Tuxes.
第三幕。死亡和燕尾服。
So let's go to the prom, you and me. Back in 1994, when I was a reporter for NPR'S All Things Considered, I covered the senior prom at Taft High School here in Chicago. We play this story now because, in contrast to the proms in Francine Pascal's books, it captures on tape what the prom usually is. Here is the very old recording.
所以让我们去舞会吧，你和我。早在1994年，当我是美国国家公共电台《万事皆备》节目的记者时，我报道了芝加哥塔夫脱高中的毕业舞会。我们现在播放这个故事是因为，与弗朗辛·帕斯卡尔书中的舞会相比，它录下了舞会通常的样子。这是当年的老录音。
All year long, the teachers see students who slouch and gossip. Students who wear clothing that teachers don't understand. Students who need prodding and discipline and constant surveillance. And then on prom night, the students reappear, transformed, as in a dream. And the teachers wander around remarking to each other, can you believe how well-behaved they are, how grown up they seem? Math teacher Jerry Pad has helped plan the prom for years.
整整一年，老师们看到的是懒散、八卦的学生。穿着老师们看不懂衣服的学生。需要督促、纪律和持续监视的学生。然后在舞会之夜，学生们重新出现，焕然一新，就像在梦中。老师们徘徊在彼此之间评论说，你能相信他们表现得多么好吗，他们看起来多么成熟？数学老师杰瑞·帕德多年来一直参与舞会的策划。
Aren't they really great? They really are. Having fun. Never having any trouble. They're just great kids. Plus these are the seniors that have made it. All the [BLEEP] are out.
他们不是真的很棒吗？他们确实如此。玩得很开心。从没出过乱子。他们真是很棒的孩子。再说这些是成功毕业的高三学生。所有的[哔——]都出局了。
Carla Revedinero's date, George Bork, hadn't bothered with a tux. He were a black shirt, skinny black tie, black pants, no jacket. They were having fun, except for one small hitch.
卡拉·瑞维迪内罗的舞伴乔治·博克甚至懒得穿燕尾服。他穿了一件黑色衬衫、细黑领带、黑色裤子，没穿外套。他们玩得很开心，除了一个小小的障碍。
Can't dance, bro.
兄弟，不会跳舞。
He won't dance with me because he can't dance.
他不跟我跳舞，因为他不会跳舞。
It's not that I won't. It's like I can't, you know?
不是我不想。是说我不会，你知道吗？
He can't, yeah.
他不会，是啊。
Maybe if they played some metal, he said, he could slam dance.
他说，如果他们放些金属乐，他说他可以蹦迪。
'94! Whoo! '94! '94.
'94！呜呼！'94！'94。
This couple was having a different kind of prom.
这对情侣度过的是另一种舞会。
We're going to Niagara Falls tomorrow morning. But tonight, we're just going to party. My girlfriend isn't telling me yet where we're going to go to the hotel room.
我们明天早上要去尼亚加拉大瀑布。但今晚，我们要去派对。我女朋友还没告诉我要去酒店房间哪里。
I went to a special place and I got him a special hotel room somewhere, and it's a surprise.
我找了个特别的地方，给他准备了一个特别的酒店房间，那是个惊喜。
What do your parents say about this?
你父母对此怎么说？
Well, my mom gave me the, you know, mother-daughter sex talk. But it's a little too late for that, so. Kind of in one ear, out the other. But she was still very worried, and she didn't want me to do this, thought I was making money. But you know.
嗯，我妈给了我那种，你知道，母女间的性教育谈话。但对我来说有点太晚了，所以。基本上左耳进右耳出。但她还是很担心，她不想让我这么做，以为我在搞钱。但你知道。
Your mother gave you a mother-daughter sex talk?
你妈给你进行了母女性教育谈话？
Yeah. Saying that-- something maybe she might-- because I'm leaving for college, OK? And since we've been together this long, it's going to be very dramatic between us two to leave each other. So she's like all, he's going to bust the moves on you, he's going to try to do sex acts to try to keep you here. But--
是的。说是——可能她想——因为我要去上大学了，好吗？既然我们在一起这么久了，我们俩分开会很戏剧化。所以她就说，他会向你出招的，他会试图通过性行为试图留住你。但——
Too late for that.
太晚了。
On the dance floor, there was a certain amount of copping feels and kissing. But the sexual tension of the prom hit a kind of surreal zenith when the DJ told the boys to bring chairs down to the dance floor. Girls were seated in the chairs. And the garter ceremony began.
在舞池里，确实有一定程度的亲热和接吻。但舞会的性张力在DJ让男孩们把椅子搬到舞池时达到了一种超现实的顶峰。女孩们坐在椅子上。吊袜带仪式开始了。
We're going to count down from 10.
我们要从10开始倒计时。
Over a hundred teenage girls presented bare legs with garters.
一百多名高中女生展示了带有吊袜带的裸腿。
All men have to put your hands behind your back.
所有男人把手放在背后。
Meaning, grab the garter with your teeth.
意思是，用牙齿抓住吊袜带。
All right. We're going to count backwards from ten. Ten, nine--
好了。我们要从十开始倒数。十，九——
This is the kind of activity that separates the "just friends" prom dates from the real dates. And dozens of "just friends" stood around the edges of the hall in various states of discomfort.
这是那种把“只是朋友”的舞伴和真正的恋人区别开来的活动。几十个“只是朋友”站在大厅边缘，表现出各种不自在。
Four, three, two, one.
四，三，二，一。
A hundred million teenage boys bring their faces up against the slightly sweaty thighs of their dates, rip multicolored garters with their teeth, and drag them off the leg. It's a shocking and amazing sight, but when I asked teachers about it later, they all say, "where have you been?  They've done this for years!" At homecoming, apparently, things get even more explicit.
一亿个高中男孩把脸贴在舞伴略带汗水的腿上，用牙齿扯下五颜六色的吊袜带，然后从腿上拖下来。这是一种令人震惊和惊人的景象，但当我后来问老师们时，他们都说：“你都去哪儿了？他们这样做很多年了！”显然在返校舞会上，事情变得更加露骨。
All right! OK. Let's move the chairs and we'll have a slow dance.
好了！好的。移开椅子，我们要跳慢舞了。
As evening wore on, George and Carla, the couple that didn't dance, did go out for a couple of slow numbers.
随着夜晚流逝，不会跳舞的情侣乔治和卡拉确实出去跳了几首慢曲。
Well, I want to get everyone to the floor.
嗯，我想让每个人都到舞池里来。
Later, when it was time to leave, they picked up their prom favors and took some balloons from the centerpieces and joined another couple, Mark and Charlotte, in Mark's father's Ford Tempo. They searched for a radio station.
后来，该离开时，他们捡起了舞会伴手礼，从餐桌装饰中拿了一些气球，和另一对情侣马克和夏洛特一起上了马克父亲的福特Tempo车。他们寻找广播电台。
Put it on CKG!
调到CKG！
Jeez, nothing but a whole bunch of hippie rock. No, man! It's a bunch of hippie rock.
天哪，除了嬉皮摇滚什么都没有。不，伙计！那是一堆嬉皮摇滚。
I like it. All right.
我喜欢。好吧。
[SINGING]
[歌唱声]
Everybody pitched in a dollar for gas. Carla waved to people in other cars and inhaled the helium from her prom balloons.
每个人凑了一美元买汽油。卡拉向其他车里的人挥手，吸入舞会气球里的氦气。
Fuzzy bunny, fuzzy bunny.
毛茸茸的兔子，毛茸茸的兔子。
They argued about directions, discussed who Winona Ryder is going out with these days. And finally, after nearly an hour, we ended up at a party. A pretty lively party, but mostly we stood around outside.
他们争论方向，讨论薇诺娜·瑞德最近和谁在约会。终于，将近一小时后，我们到了一个派对。一个相当热闹的派对，但我们大多只是站在外面。
Where's my liquor!
我的酒在哪儿！
In the store!
在店里！
Matt, where's my liquor?
马特，我的酒在哪儿？
Charlotte repeated this about, oh, 20 times. Nobody else seemed too interested in getting drunk. But finally someone organized a liquor run.
夏洛特大概重复了这句二十遍。其他人似乎对买醉不太感兴趣。但最终有人组织了一次买酒行动。
Are they going to sell to you?
他们会卖给你吗？
They'll sell to me. If they don't sell to me, the'll sell to someone else. What do you want?
他们会卖给我的。如果他们不卖给我，他们会卖给别人。你想要什么？
Kiwi Lime Mad Dog, baby.
猕猴桃青柠疯狂狗，宝贝。
Mad Dog? What kind? Kiwi Lime?
疯狂狗？哪种？猕猴桃青柠？
Wait! He needs something.
等等！他需要点东西。
Give me that 5-pack. Here, I'll give you 10.
给我那个五连装。给，我给你10块钱。
One thing you forget when you're not a teenager is how much time teenagers spend just standing around, waiting. Waiting to get organized. Waiting for everyone to show up. Waiting for the person buying liquor to return. Percentage-wise, this was the largest part of the evening. Invariably, during this time, someone starts to get on someone else's nerves. For Charlotte and George, the feeling was mutual.
当你不再是青少年时，你会忘记青少年花多少时间只是站在那里等待。等待组织起来。等待每个人到齐。等待买酒的人回来。按百分比计算，这是夜晚最长的一部分。这段时间里，总有人开始让别人心烦。对于夏洛特和乔治来说，这种感觉是相互的。
She always yaps, man. She never shuts up. She just keeps on talking and talking. It's like-- I wonder if she'll shut up! And it's like the tone of voice she uses, too. She's like a whiny-- ehhh! Tone of voice, you know. It's like, I don't want to hear it. I don't put up with her-- when she first started going to Taft, man, and I hated it then and I hate it now. It's like something that's bringing me down, you know?
她总是喋喋不休，伙计。她从不闭嘴。她只是不停地说啊说。就像——我真想知道她什么时候闭嘴！还有她用的那种语气，也是。她像个爱发牢骚的——呃！那种语气，你知道吗。我不想听。我不忍受她——当她刚开始去塔夫脱时，伙计，那时我就讨厌，现在我也讨厌。这就像某种让我沮丧的事情，你知道吗？
Go on, man. Go on!
得了吧，伙计。得了吧！
You're coming with us?
你跟我们一起去？
Around 1:30, a decision was made to go to the beach-- one of Chicago's downtown Lake Michigan beaches. And after much debate and four attempts to get a dozen people into cars, we finally drove to Belmont Harbor and walked out to the big rocks on the water.
大约一点半，大家决定去海滩——芝加哥市中心密歇根湖的海滩之一。在经过一番辩论和四次试图把十几个人塞进车里后，我们终于开车去了贝尔蒙特港，走到了水边的大石头上。
Everyone stared at the lake. The city lights made the clouds glow orange. In the distance you could see some fog and the lights of the water pumping rig.
每个人都盯着湖面。城市灯光使云层发出橙色的光芒。在远处你可以看到一些雾气和抽水装置的灯光。
Those pumping stations, man. How'd do you like to work out there? You'd get to work out there for three days. Three-day shifts. 24 hours. The boats would be out there. And they feed you. You work and you get paid and you just hang around there. And it's like a real cool city job that you get paid through the ass for.
那些抽水站，伙计。你想在那儿工作吗？你可以在那儿工作三天。三天轮班。24小时。船会停在那儿。他们管你饭。你工作，你拿到报酬，你只是在那儿闲逛。这就像一份非常酷的城市工作，你赚得盆满钵满。
It'd be so scary to be on a boat. You know, it's so dark.
待在船上太可怕了。你知道，天太黑了。
Unless I'm really smashed, I really feel uneasy around open water.
除非我烂醉，否则我真的对开阔水域感到不安。
Did you say you feel uneasy about what?
你是说你对什么感到不安？
Water, open water.
水，开阔水域。
The lake, man.
湖，伙计。
Cool, man. Space. It's free, man. Best you can go.
酷，伙计。空间。它是自由的，伙计。你所能去的最好的地方。
Mark then applied fairly dire speech which, coming from him, is surprising. He's college-bound, a good student, on the football team, usually easy-going and self-confident.
马克随后发表了一番相当可怕的演讲，这对他来说令人惊讶。他要上大学了，是个好学生，在橄榄球队，通常随和且自信。
Seriously, man, there is no [BLEEP] freedom in this goddamn place, man. There's always some cop or somebody asking what you're doing. There's always somebody who owns the place. They're always going to come to you and ask you, you know, especially when you're underage. Then they're going to really get on your back. Lectures about what you're not supposed to know, what you're supposed to.
说真的，伙计，这个该死的地方根本没有[哔——]自由，伙计。总是有警察或某人在问你在做什么。总有人拥有这个地方。他们总会过来问你，你知道，尤其是当你未成年的时候。然后他们真的会找你麻烦。对你进行关于你不知道的、你该知道什么的讲座。
Blair and Charlotte go off for cigarettes. Carla takes her shoes off. We talk about this and that. And then we look behind us and see the blue lights through the trees.
布莱尔和夏洛特出去抽烟了。卡拉脱下了鞋子。我们谈论着这个那个。然后我们回头看到树木间闪烁的蓝光。
Cops.
警察。
No evening like this could be complete without a run-in with the police. They're perhaps 100 yards away in the parking lot in their squad car.
没有这种夜晚会缺少与警察的交锋。他们就在大约100码外的停车场警车里。
Are they getting out?
他们要出来吗？
The police hover there a few minutes, put a ticket on one kid's car, and drive off. No big deal.
警察在那里徘徊了几分钟，给一个孩子的车贴了张罚单，然后开车走了。没什么大不了的。
Next stop, naturally, is an all-night restaurant. But the time we hold the big plastic Denny's menus in our hands, it's four in the morning.
下一站，自然是通宵餐厅。当我们手里拿着丹尼餐厅那种大的塑料菜单时，已经是凌晨四点了。
You ready to order?
准备好点餐了吗？
I want salad.
我要沙拉。
You know what I'm going to have? The Flanagan slam.
你知道我要吃什么吗？弗拉纳根满贯餐。
They gossipped. They floated pleasantly from topic to topic. Fate had handed them a prom, and they knew they were supposed to stay out all night, and they kept wandering from place to place, waiting for something to happen. Nothing much did, but nothing bad did, either.
他们八卦着。他们在话题之间愉快地游走。命运给了他们一个舞会，他们知道他们被要求整晚不回家，他们不停地从一个地方走到另一个地方，等待着什么事情发生。没发生什么大事，也没发生什么坏事。
It's starting to get light outside.
外面开始变亮了。
People have got to get going soon. I'm going to sleep all day.
人们很快得走了。我要睡一整天。
I can't sleep all day.
我不能睡一整天。
Back in the car, George said that the best moment of the problem was when he got to slow dance with Carla. Mark said it was when he missed getting a ticket from those cops. Charlotte said it was when she looked around at all the people at the prom and realized that she no longer had to return to Taft High School.
在车里，乔治说舞会最棒的时刻是他和卡拉跳慢舞的时候。马克说最棒的是他没被那些警察开罚单。夏洛特说最棒的是当她环顾舞会上的人时，意识到她再也不用回到塔夫脱高中了。
Act Four. Only One Thing Missing.
第四幕。只缺一件事。
Every year for the past 50 years, on the third weekend in May, all the high schools in Racine, Wisconsin hold their problems. On that same night, after all the proms have ended, kids from all seven schools drive a parade route through town in convertibles and limos and antique cars, ice cream trucks and semis, to the post-prom party, which in Racine is actually bigger than prom itself. Hosted by the local Rotary Club, it goes from 9:30 in the evening until 3:30 the next morning. People set up lawn chairs to watch the procession of cars. It is a huge, huge big deal. And then 19 years ago it got bigger. Wendy Dorr tells the tale.
在过去50年的每一年，五月的第三个周末，威斯康星州拉辛市的所有高中都会举办他们的舞会。在同一个夜晚，所有舞会结束后，来自所有七所学校的孩子们开着敞篷车、豪华轿车、古董车、冰激凌车和半挂车，沿着游行路线穿过城镇，前往舞会后派对，在拉辛，这个派对实际上比舞会本身还要大。由当地扶轮社主办，从晚上9:30一直持续到第二天凌晨3:30。人们摆放草坪椅观看车队。这真是件天大的事。然后19年前，它变得更大了。温迪·多尔讲述了这个传说。
The good people of Racine loved their prom, and they were always looking for ways to make it better. And so they added to it a force even more powerful than the prom itself. They added live television coverage.
拉辛善良的人们热爱他们的舞会，他们总是在寻找让它变得更好的方法。所以他们为它增加了一种比舞会本身更强大的力量。他们增加了电视直播报道。
Last year, 60,000 eyes were watching a rite of passage. Seven schools. One great location. One night only. It's prom. Prom. Live. Saturday, May 19, 9:30 PM. What will you be wearing?
去年，6万只眼睛在注视着这一人生礼仪。七所学校。一个绝佳地点。仅此一夜。这是舞会。舞会。直播。5月19日周六，晚上9:30。你会穿什么？
It's a really, really incredible atmosphere in there with an $8,000 laser show, $5,000 to $10,000 worth of balloons and flowers--
那里的氛围真是太不可思议了，有价值8000美元的激光秀，价值5000到10000美元的气球和鲜花——
Craig Haskins has been running the Rotary Club's post-prom for the past couple of years. He was voted into the job by his fellow Rotarians simply because he is 27 years old and by far the youngest Rotarian in Racine. And he looks young. On prom night he has to wear a special badge so the high school kids know not to ask him to dance.
克雷格·哈斯金斯在过去几年里一直在负责扶轮社的舞会后派对。他被同僚扶轮社员选为这项工作，仅仅因为他27岁，是拉辛最年轻的扶轮社员。他看起来很年轻。在舞会之夜，他必须戴上一枚特殊的徽章，好让高中生们知道不要邀请他跳舞。
There's screaming people. The red carpet. Television crews. Two talented-- you know, like the host and hostess that interview you when you walk through the door. Just like Joan Crawford. That's her name, right?
到处是尖叫的人。红地毯。电视摄制组。两位才华横溢——你知道，就像你在进门时采访你的主持人和女主持人。就像琼·克劳馥。那是她的名字，对吧？
Joan Rivers.
琼·里弗斯。
Joan Rivers. Just like Joan Rivers. When you walk through, what are you wearing? You know, that's a beautiful tux, or nice dress.
琼·里弗斯。就像琼·里弗斯。当你走进来时，你穿的是什么？你知道，那是件漂亮的燕尾服，或者漂亮的礼服。
Good evening, everyone, and welcome to Time Warner Cable's coverage of the 2001 Rotary Post-Prom Parade, live from Festival Hall on Racine's Lakefront. My name Deb Silverton--
晚上好，各位，欢迎收看时代华纳有线电视对2001年扶轮社舞会后游行的报道，直播来自拉辛湖滨的节日大厅。我是黛布·西尔弗顿——
When I was walking down the red carpet, I felt like I was-- you feel like a celebrity.
当我走在红地毯上时，我觉得我——你感觉自己像个名人。
Zach Fishbain was a senior at Horlick High this year.
扎克·费什贝恩今年是霍利克高中的高三学生。
And there's fans. People of all ages. There's bleachers, packed bleachers, hundreds of people around the arrival area. And people screaming your name, taking pictures, holding their hands out. Feels like the paparazzi are like following me around with television, cameras in your face?
还有粉丝。各个年龄段的人。还有看台，挤满了看台，数百人聚集在到达区。人们尖叫着你的名字，拍照，伸出手。感觉像是狗仔队跟着我到处走，有电视，摄像机怼在你的脸上？
What did you do before you got here?
你来这儿之前做了什么？
We went down to the country club and ate with the rest of everybody.
我们去了乡村俱乐部，和大家一起吃了饭。
The whole school did.
整个学校都去了。
OK. So you all ate together and then came down here.
好的。所以你们都在一起吃完饭，然后来到这儿。
There's people on the left of the carpet interviewing and watching all these limousines and friends coming in. Everyone feels like a celebrity and everyone sees everyone else as a celebrity. You walk in and you see the strobe lights flashing. And the celebrity feeling is even multiplied when you get there.
地毯左边有人在采访并观看所有这些进场的豪华轿车和朋友们。每个人都觉得自己是个名人，每个人也都把别人看作名人。你走进去，看到闪烁的频闪灯。当你到达那里时，这种名人感甚至被放大了。
And that feeling doesn't go away until-- well, I still have it three weeks later. And I'm still like a celebrity, watching it all again on television. So as long as you keep watching it and everyone knows how big of a deal it is, it really isn't downplayed. Once you kind of lose that feeling, you think about prom and start talking about it again.
那种感觉直到——嗯，三周后我依然有。我依然像个名人，在电视上看着这一切重播。所以只要你一直看，每个人都知道这是件大事，它就真的没有被淡化。一旦你那种感觉消失了，你想到舞会又开始谈论它。
And people want to hear about it. People who didn't go and watching it have so many questions for you. Did you do this? Did you see this person? What kind of music did they play? You are the center of attention when prom is the topic. So you maintain that celebrity feeling.
人们想听关于它的事。没去过、看着它的人有很多问题要问你。你做了这个吗？你看到那个人了吗？他们放了什么音乐？当舞会成为话题时，你就是关注的中心。所以你保持着那种名人感。
Here's what it looks like to the home viewer. Because this is low-budget local cable programming, it's mostly just one camera shot. Couples enter the festival hall, passing two by two in front of the camera, whoo-hooing and hi-Momming straight into the camera, one after the next. And this goes on for four hours.
这是家庭观众看到的景象。因为这是低成本的本地有线电视节目，大部分只是一个固定机位镜头。情侣们进入节日大厅，成双成对地在摄像机前经过，对着摄像机欢呼、向妈妈打招呼，一个接一个。这持续了四个小时。
In Zach's house, this footage has become a kind of video wallpaper. While I was there interviewing him, a copy of the cable broadcast played the whole time in the living room. Sometimes a family member would drop out of the conversation to stare at it for a while. Now and then, Zach's mom Susan would call our attention to the screen.
在扎克家，这些录像成了某种视频壁纸。当我在那儿采访他时，有线电视节目的副本在客厅里一直播放着。有时家庭成员会脱离谈话盯着它看一会儿。时而扎克的妈妈苏珊会把我们的注意力引向屏幕。
Here he comes! Look how handsome.
他来了！看他多帅。
We have been so excited that we've watched it numerous times. It's great. You know, we have two copies of it. It's in two TVs. And every time you watch it when you see somebody different. And it's so much fun when you run into the parents and the kids in the study. You know? To say, your pink dress and your matching tux was just great. And it's great.
我们太兴奋了，已经看了无数次。太棒了。你知道，我们有两份副本。它在两台电视里。每次看你都会看到不同的人。当你在学习中遇到家长和孩子们时，这太有趣了。你知道吗？去说，你那件粉色礼服和配套的燕尾服太棒了。太棒了。
If you ask the local television studios what's the biggest--
如果你问当地电视台什么是最大的——
Agian, Craig Haskins.
又是克雷格·哈斯金斯。
The Oscars, Super Bowl, or Prom, they would hands down say "Prom." Because it's the highest-rated anything in town. And that's a good way to judge people's interest, is what they're watching on TV.
奥斯卡、超级碗或舞会，他们会毫不犹豫地说“舞会”。因为它是镇上收视率最高的节目。评价人们的兴趣，看看他们在电视上在看什么，是一个很好的方法。
Proms everywhere are all about hype. And so it's no surprise that once you have a prom as a TV show that the ratings would be hyped, too. The cable company's commercial says that 60,000 eyes were watching the prom. But by that, they actually mean 30,000 viewers. Two eyes per viewer. And really, even that number is just a guess.
各地的舞会都是关于炒作的。所以毫不奇怪，一旦你把舞会作为电视节目，收视率也会被炒作。有线电视公司的广告说有6万只眼睛在注视着舞会。但通过那个，他们实际上指的是3万名观众。每个观众两只眼。而且实际上，即使那个数字也只是猜测。
For sure one person who wasn't watching the problem was Kirsten Hitzky. I spoke with her at job at Desmond's Formal Wear, a tuxedo rental store at the Regency Mall. It is also safe to say that Kirsten was the only person in the mall that night who was reading Plato's Phaedrus for fun.
肯定有一个没看舞会的人是克里斯汀·希茨基。我在戴斯蒙德正式服装店工作时和她交谈，那是一家位于摄政商场的燕尾服租赁店。可以肯定地说，克里斯汀是当晚商场里唯一一个在津津有味地阅读柏拉图《斐德罗篇》的人。
I'm rereading it. It was the last thing I read in school, and it was really wonderful, and I wanted to keep reading it. And also, I can practice my Greek.
我在重读它。这是我在学校读的最后的东西，它真的很棒，我想继续读下去。而且，我也可以练习我的希腊语。
You didn't go to prom.
你没去舞会。
No, no, I didn't. Prom is a beautiful illusion.
不，不，我没去。舞会是一种美丽的幻觉。
If you're someone who hates the prom, there's no better way to refuel your hatred than by working at a tux shop. Kirsten says everyone at the store despises the prom. The worst part being when the kids bring their sweaty suits back.
如果你是一个讨厌舞会的人，没有比在燕尾服店工作更好的方式来助长你的仇恨了。克里斯汀说店里的每个人都鄙视舞会。最糟糕的部分是孩子们把汗津津的西装拿回来的时候。
Sometimes they'll come out stuffed into a little grocery bag, tied really tight. And you have to pretty much disinfect the whole thing and pick it up very lightly. The boss here got fungus underneath her fingernails one time from dealing with someone's socks.
有时他们会把它塞进一个小杂货袋里，扎得很紧。你基本上必须对整件东西进行消毒，并非常轻地拿起它。这里的老板有一次因为处理某人的袜子，指甲下面长了真菌。
Do you get suits with, like, grass stains?
你们会收到带有草渍之类的西装吗？
Oh yeah. Grass. Puke. Mud.
哦，是的。草渍。呕吐物。泥巴。
For people that say that prom is there for people feel special for once in their lives, I don't know about that. I mean, find me one high school senior who really needs an ego boost. It's the time to be cocky and prideful. And I think it's kind of indulgent of that. And if they say that they feel like a celebrity, it doesn't surprise me at all. Because they, you know, they do get treated like celebrities, even though their personality might be less than beautiful. And I'm certainly glad I didn't take part in it.
对于那些说舞会是为了让人一生中感觉特别一次的人，我对此持怀疑态度。我是说，给我找一个真正需要虚荣心提升的高中高三学生。那是傲慢自大的时候。我认为这是一种放纵。如果他们说他们感觉像个名人，我一点也不觉得奇怪。因为他们，你知道，确实得到了像名人一样的待遇，尽管他们的个性可能不那么美好。我当然很高兴我没参与其中。
To truly enjoy the Racine prom, and maybe to enjoy any prom, you have to be the sort of person who enjoys the hype leading up to it. Zach certainly did for basically his whole life.
要真正享受拉辛舞会，也许要享受任何舞会，你必须是那种享受它之前炒作的人。扎克显然基本上他整个人生都是这样。
I have been watching prom on television every spring. Every May. And it's only natural middle schoolers, elementary school, grade school, high school-- all ages are watching this. So every year we watch it. And as a kid, I thought I was going to come in a helicopter, or with a yellow tuxedo. Actually this year there was a kid in a yellow tuxedo. But no helicopters, unfortunately.
我每年春天都在电视上看舞会。每年五月。这太自然了，中学生、小学生、小学、高中——所有年龄段的人都在看。所以我们每年都看。小时候，我想过我会坐直升机来，或者穿着黄色燕尾服。其实今年确实有个孩子穿着黄色燕尾服。但很遗憾没有直升机。
Watching it on TV-- I just never realized how glorious this festivity really was until I actually was a part of it. I mean, it seems great. You look so forward to it. And it was even better when I got there. Because it was the real thing. I was experiencing it. The realization, the fact that I knew I was actually there and no longer looking forward to it made it that much better.
在电视上看——我从未意识到这场庆典实际上有多辉煌，直到我真正参与其中。我是说，它看起来很棒。你非常期待它。当我到达那里时，它甚至更好。因为那是真实的东西。我在体验它。这种实现，我知道我实际上就在那里、不再只是期待它的事实，让它变得好多了。
Prom, after all, is just a dance. Plus a whole lot of hype. Racine understands this so well that it's possible they've created the greatest prom in the world. They've hyped it to the point that when I asked a bunch of junior high school girls if they were looking forward to the prom, all of them look at me as if I'd just ask them if they were, in fact, of the human species. Because they explained, by the time they reach senior year, who knows how big it could get.
舞会，毕竟，只是个舞会。再加上一大堆炒作。拉辛非常了解这一点，以至于他们可能创造了世界上最棒的舞会。他们把它炒作到了这种程度：当我问一群初中女生是否期待舞会时，她们所有人都看着我，就好像我问她们是不是人类物种一样。因为她们解释说，等到她们高三时，谁知道它会变得多大。
Wendy Dorr.
温迪·多尔。
Special thanks to OVO Incorporated, an arts collective in New York. It is from them that we heard about the prom in Racine. They made a film about it called World's Best Prom. They were very helpful. For information about them and their films, visit their website, www.worldsbestprom.com.
特别感谢纽约的艺术团体OVO公司。正是从他们那里我们听说了拉辛的舞会。他们制作了一部关于它的电影，叫《世界最棒舞会》。他们非常有帮助。有关他们和他们电影的信息，请访问他们的网站，www.worldsbestprom.com。
Well, our program was produced today by Starlee Kine and myself with Alex Blumberg, Wendy Dorr, and Jonathan Goldstein. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Todd Bachmann, Paul McCarthy, Seth Lind, and Emily Yusef.
好了，我们的节目今天由斯塔莉·凯恩和我自己，以及亚历克斯·布隆伯格、温迪·多尔和乔纳森·戈德斯坦制作。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作协助来自托德·巴赫曼、保罗·麦卡锡、塞斯·林德和艾米莉·尤瑟夫。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is heard every week by over four million ears. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》每周有超过四百万听众。本节目由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金支持鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss Mr. Torey Malatia, who describes his job this way:
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板托雷·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他这样描述他的工作：
You work and you get paid and you just hang around there. And it's like a real cool city job that you get paid through the ass for.
你工作，你拿到报酬，你只是在那儿闲逛。这就像一份非常酷的城市工作，你赚得盆满钵满。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。